der erst den redner nach der kanzlerin
ist christian winterlingen und kollegen
die frau bundeskanzlerin hat ihre rede
geschlossen mit einem optimistisch
humoristischen gruß an ihren
koalitionspartner
begonnen hat sie mit einem
außenpolitischen schwerpunkt das ist
auch nachvollziehbar
frau bundeskanzlerin denn einer unserer
engsten verbündeten fordert unser land
ja heute in einem zeitungsinterview
bei bild dazu auf unsere führungsrolle
wahrzunehmen
insofern nachvollziehbar dass sie hier
einen außenpolitischen schwerpunkt
setzen aber wir hätten dann erwartet
dass sie auch die großen linien
aufzeigen dass sie nicht im klein-klein
verbleiben
sie haben zu recht gesagt es muss eine
europäische antwort auf die
herausforderung china geben ja aber
bitte welche antwort denn dann ist
reicht nicht nur fragen aufzuwerfen
wir hätten erwartet von bundeskanzlerin
werden erwartet wenn sie über
krisenregionen sprechen dass sie
persönlich stellung beziehen wo sie
eigentlich politisch stehen in der frage
nordsyrien stehen sie an der seite der
bundesverteidigungsministerium die eine
strategische initiative ergriffen hat
oder an der seite des
bundesaußenministers maß der in ankara
die uneinigkeit der deutschen
bundesregierung auf internationaler
bühne dokumentiert hat und und wenn sie
wenn sie ihre rede frau bundeskanzlerin
hier
zum anlass nehmen 70 jahren nato zu
würdigen
dann hätten wir ein ganz klares
bekenntnis zur transatlantischen
partnerschaft erwartet der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hat eine
unglaubliche entgleisung in den letzten
tagen ja politisch sich geleistet die
entgleisung nämlich die vereinigten
staaten von amerika mit der
volksrepublik china in einem satz zu
sagen sie hätten dass sie heute aus der
welt schaffen müssen war bundeskanzler
bemerkenswert ist nun vorüber sie da
allerdings nicht gesprochen haben also
ein großer schwerpunkt außenpolitik aber
worüber haben sie nicht gesprochen oder
nur sehr kurz sie haben nicht darüber
gesprochen dass die deutsche wirtschaft
nicht mehr wächst 0,1 prozent wir sind
ganz hinten in der europäischen union es
gibt keinerlei wachstumsdynamik mehr bei
uns gerade mal knapp viereinhalb minuten
haben sie auf die wirtschaftliche lage
in engeren sinne verwendet frau
bundeskanzlerin viereinhalb minuten zu
einer der wesentlichen grundfragen der
nächsten jahre hier in diesem land kann
nur sagen wer die wirtschaft links
liegen lässt darf sich über probleme von
rechts irgendwann nicht wundern nichts
dazu
sie haben allerdings dann angesprochen
9500 arbeitsplätze die bei audi abgebaut
werden
und das hat nicht nur was mit
konjunkturellen fragen zu unserer das
sind auch politische entscheidungen
dazu führen wir konzentrieren uns in
deutschland und sie haben das hier
unterstrichen jagd ganz einseitig nur
auf die elektromobilität
obwohl es alternativen gibt wasserstoff
fahrig synthetische kraftstoffe vieles
mehr was denkbar ist wir konzentrieren
uns nur auf die elektromobilität und das
führt natürlich zu einem massiven abbau
von arbeitsplätzen in den unternehmen
die auf diesel technologie gesetzt haben
sie haben dazu heute mehr oder weniger
nichts gesagt sondern das nur
hingenommen
der bundesparteitag der cdu der war da
weiter dort gab es das klare bekenntnis
in deutschland hat auch der nicht fossil
betriebene verbrennungsmotor als
spitzentechnologie eine zukunft ich muss
ihnen sagen die cdu gefällt mir besser
als diese bundesregierung ja auch in
anderen fragen man diese bundesregierung
geht ja schlafwandlerisch auf eine
drohende wirtschaftskrise
schlafwandlerisch auf einem
wirtschaftsabsturz zu aber ich sehe auf
der anderen seite dass es durchaus jahr
andere erkenntnisse gibt sie kündigen
bisschen wachs reich an mittelfristig
müsste man mal prüfen da etwas bei den
unternehmenssteuern zu tun
das ist auf einer linie die wir kennen
am peter altmeier als kommissarischen
finanzminister ist damals ja die
vollständige abschaffung des
solidaritätszuschlags gescheitert an
seinem zahlengerüst und dem unwillen
aber der cdu-bundesparteitag da gab es
klare aussagen zum ersten ersten 2020
den soli für alle abzuschaffen und ihn
nicht zu einer strafsteuer für
mittelstand und wirtschaft zu machen ich
kann ihnen nur sagen bringen sie das als
gesetzentwurf hier ein unsere zu
ist ihnen da sicher sie haben ja immer
die bedeutung der digital politik
gesprochen frau bundeskanzlerin in der
tat auch da müssen wir tempo aufnehmen
wenn der auf höhe der zeit sein wollen
das haben wir ja schon öfter besprochen
damit ihr tempo aufnehmen nur noch weg
aus der der praxis der rohrpost dies ja
auch im bundeskanzleramt noch gibt so
müssen hin auch zu modernen
verwaltungshandeln zu einem management
der transformation digitalisierung aus
einer hand dazu wäre es empfehlenswert
alle kompetenzen und ressourcen auch an
einer stelle in einem digital
ministerium zu bündeln
bislang ist das an der union gescheitert
jetzt höre ich auf dem bundesparteitag
der cdu also eigentlich bräuchte man an
digital ministerium willkommen im klub
und sogar der chef des
bundeskanzleramtes das sagt wir brauchen
ein digital ministerium frau
bundeskanzlerin lassen sie der guten
erkenntnis doch einfach taten folgen
oder unterwegs an der spd wählen sich
die spd den ekligen bonbon ans revers
kleben lassen das ist an irgend
scheitert dass wir nicht ein zentrales
management der digitalisierung bekommen
also eigentlich sind doch alle außer den
grünen einer meinung wir brauchen so was
ja sie haben eingerichtet ein heimat
ministerium weil auch seehofer in bayern
keine mehrheit was uns aber noch fehlt
es an digital ministerium damit sie auch
die zukunftsfragen an gelten also lassen
sie den guten erkenntnissen ihres
parteitags im regierungshandeln taten
folgen
zweites thema über das sie nicht
gesprochen haben wir die balance
seehofer die zahl der baugenehmigungen
in deutschland ist eingebrochen
die wohnraum offensive dieser
bundesregierung ist bereits gescheitert
bevor sie begonnen hat ist eine der
wesen
in sozialfragen unserer zeit und schon
nach zwei jahren sprechen alle zahlen
dagegen das hat gründe
ein grund ist dass die politik in dieser
bundesregierung nur die latte behandelt
wird bei den großen branchen ereignissen
tritt der bundesbauminister überhaupt
gar nicht in erscheinung war
möglicherweise ein organisatorischer
fehler eine riesen ressort ihn und bau
überhaupt ins leben zu rufen
aber sei es drum das sind dinge die hier
in dieser bundesregierung zu
verantworten sind schwerwiegender wiegen
landespolitische entscheidungen
insbesondere hier in berlin
die das vertrauen von menschen die in
wohnraum investieren wollen dabei sind
vollkommen zu zerstören der mieten
deckel die in berlin der mieten deckel
hier in berlin rot rot grüner nieten
deckel in berlin
der ist eine gute sache gute sache
dietmar bartsch es sind hier in berlin
doch sofort bauanträge zurückgezogen
worden und nicht von irgendwelchen
heuschrecken sondern ausgerechnet
genossenschaftliche wohnung in italy
beziehen ihre anträge zurück weil sie
sagen es gibt ja keine
planungssicherheit mehr
wir sind dabei einen eckpfeiler unserer
wirtschaftsordnung einzureißen wurde
eine rot rot grüne politik das ist gut
gemeint aber wir sehen inzwischen die
verheerungen die fehlen uns fehlen 1,9
millionen wohnungen in deutschland 300
milliarden euro investitionsvolumen
woher soll das geld kommen wenn nicht
von privaten investoren es wird aber
niemand in wohnraum investieren wenn er
sicher sein kann dass sein eigentum und
die verfügbarkeit darüber gesichert ist
und deshalb und deshalb
ich sehe vereinzelt applaus bei den
kolleginnen und kollegen der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
wenn sie das so sehen dann gehen sie mit
uns nach karlsruhe und klagen gegen die
mieten deckel von berlin
herzliche einladung an das hat nichts
mit lobby partei zu tun fdp
und wenn uns und wenn dann sind wir eine
lobby für bezahlbares und also
ausgerechnet die linkspartei
ausgerechnet die linkspartei die 40
jahre hat beweisen können dass staatlich
zentrierte wohnungspolitik nicht sozial
ist sollte in dieser frage zurückhaltung
üben denn in deutschland west wenn in
deutschland west
denn in deutschland bestzeit 1 149 sind
größte herausforderungen auch nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg inklusive der
integration in wohnungsmarkt
arbeitsmarkt von vertriebenen gelungen
mit einer privaten marktwirtschaftlichen
wohnungsbaupolitik da brauchen wir uns
also von ihnen nicht belehren zu lassen
drittes thema frau bundeskanzlerin
drittes thema über das sie nicht
gesprochen haben in der vergangenheit
haben sie oft als ziel ausgegeben
deutschland müsste eine bildungsrepublik
werden und dieses ziel ist vollkommen
richtig ist eine der der
gesellschaftskritischen schlüsselaufgabe
den fatalen zusammenhang zwischen der
herkunft aus dem elternhaus und den
beruflichen weg in deutschland zu
entkoppeln das ist das
aufstiegsversprechen unseres landes das
egal wo du geboren bist egal in welchem
stadtteil unabhängig davon wer deine
eltern sind und wo sie wo sie herkommen
dass du in deutschland alle chancen hast
das gehört zu unserer
gesellschaftsordnung dazu deshalb
bildung ganz nach vorne zu setzen
das wäre sinnvoll und richtig im sinne
ihres ziels der bildungsrepublik aber
wie ist denn die traurige realität
der nationale bildungsrat von ihnen ins
schaufenster gestellt der iss bevor
überhaupt die arbeit aufnehmen konnte
bereits gescheitert weil bayern und
baden württemberg csu und grüne sich
einer systematischen zusammenarbeit der
16 länder verweigern
ich habe verständnis dafür dass bayern
und baden württemberg bei den
bildungsstandards nicht auf das niveau
von bremen kommen wollen für die
befürchtung habe ich verständnis
die wahrheit ist aber dass bayern und
baden württemberg dort nicht in einem
wettbewerb mit bremen stehen sondern die
bundesrepublik deutschland steht in
einem wettbewerb mit den usa und asien
und selbst bayern hat im vergleich zu
den spitzenreitern auf der welt noch
viel aufzuholen besser brauchen wir mehr
vergleichbarkeit der mobilität und im
übrigen auch die gesamtstaatlichen
finanzierungsmöglichkeiten in der
bildung
das ist keine keine aufgabe mehr die die
schwächsten glieder unseres gemeinwesens
nämlich kommunen und länder alleine
stemmen können daher engagement des
bundes gefordert an ausweislich der
haushaltszahlen gibt es aber nicht mehr
engagement des bundes in der bildung
sondern bei frau carlitscheck werden 70
millionen euro sogar noch gekürzt im
haushaltsansatz 70 millionen euro die
fehlen
hier hätte man einen schwerpunkt setzen
müssen wir bräuchten nicht nur eine
exzellenzinitiative für die hochschule
sondern auch eine exzellenzinitiative
für die berufliche bildung wir müssten
nicht reden über das lebensbegleitende
lernen wir müssten es finanzieren
das wäre eine zukunftsweisende politik
und im bildungsbereich da ist es
symptomatisch dass sie ihn gar nicht
erwähnt haben passiert leider nichts
worüber sie gesprochen haben frau
bundeskanzlerin
das waren die bauern proteste vom
gestrigen tag damit haben sie
beschlossen und sie haben hier
freundliche worte geäußert
die hätten sie einmal gestern den
landwirten entgegen bringen sollen
ja ist ein ernsthaftes thema ich habe
nämlich das gefühl ich hab euch also bei
so manchem manche so aufstehen
das ist irgend ein bisschen muss man
aufpassen wird deformation professionell
um nicht zu sagen eine berufskrankheit
hier im deutschen bundestag
hier sprechen nämlich ganz viele über
die lebenswirklichkeit von menschen die
sie in wahrheit gar nicht kennen sind
ganz großes problem
ja ja das ganz ganz viele tun das ist es
bemerkenswert dass ein kollege der ich
finde es bemerkenswert ich meinte die
grünen aber ein kollege der union fühlt
sie angesprochen so ist doch ein problem
frau bundeskanzlerin wieder gesprochen
wird die brauchen keine worte
sie haben das gefühl dass hier im
parlament über sie über die berufliche
existenz entschieden wird aus
irgendeiner besagen moralischen
motivation heraus oder die tatsächliche
berufliche praxis und die
wissenschaftliche evidenz zu kennen
und das macht die leute wütend die haben
das gefühl dass die stimmungen
entscheiden und nicht fakten und viele
menschen haben das gefühl vom
dieselfahrer bis hin zum land gehört
dass hier im deutschen bundestag den
menschen der respekt versagt wird vor
der art wie sie leben und wie sie
wirtschaften und das ist ein
grundproblem frau bundeskanzlerin der
politik der vergangenen jahre
ein grundproblem der politik der
vergangenen jahre das zeigt sich bei
jeder form der bürokratisierung und
jetzt gar nichts comic zum zum schluss
weil sie sich so aufregen
weil sich aber dann ist ja ordentlich
leben hier in der bude und dann komme
ich mal dann komme ich mal komme ich
tatsächlich zum zum ende der
ausführungen und kann ich ihnen nicht
ersparen war es gibt ein symptom
man kümmert sich nicht um die wirklich
wichtigen fragen die situation der
wirtschaft spielt keine rolle und es
gibt ein klima des misstrauens und der
bevormundung das von der regierung
ausgerissen sie was dafür dass im turm
ist die wesentliche
wirtschaftspolitische maßnahme des
jahres 2020 ist ausgerechnet die
einführung einer bong schlicht weil man
glaubt dass wenn beim bäcker die
kaffeetasse ausgegeben wird dass das
steuerhinterziehung betrieben wird und
das ist symptomatisch bürokratismus
viele kosten misstrauen ohne einen
wirklichen nutzen dafür dass unser land
vorankommt leider symptomatisch für die
art wie hier regiert wird